let's just start off with this let's get
your relationship status oh and then how
you make your money these days I I'm my
relationship status is running up my
high score I want to get a four digit
crap you know you're running up your
body count yeah okay and then uh I'm
also I I don't I mean I just you want to
brag about all the money stuff I want
you to brag okay
do not be humble bro so you're dripped
out with I don't know what's going on
here brother do not TV which TV which TV
am I looking at which screen go straight
right
yeah let's go I see you over there okay
hi Richard Hart on the world's largest
diamond you do not okay I don't care
what you do I don't care how do you work
you can't own the world as Diamond the
largest diamond I own it me you don't
okay get that right right now second I
raised 27 for charity you ain't raised
27 charity but you probably think you're
a better person to me LOL you ain't I'm
the free self-help author that wrote two
books that you could download for free T
dot I mean slash s-c-i-v-i-v-e but since
I don't charge from people don't read
them so I'm gonna have to start charging
for them so y'all actually read them I
designed a cryptocurrency went up and
priced ten thousand fold in 623 days
that's 10 000 X that's a million percent
perfect Flawless operation for a
thousand days and if you staked it you
made more you could have made you know
50 more could have made like
1.5 million percent
I'm just gonna start it man I got 10
million dollars of wrist watches and I'm
in profit on them so I made money
flexing who's making money flexing all
y'all people wasting money in the club
you ain't making money on that I flex
and make money at the same time genius
got three million dollars in cars I got
the thousand horsepower Ferrari I had
the most expensive Rolexes ever made and
I've done the world's largest free
airdrop so if you've got coins on
ethereum or uh you know ethereum itself
you're gonna get a copy of that free on
a new network you only got to do nothing
no sign up no mL no kyc no nothing it
just works you go play with your coins
in a test net right now it's been
working great for eight months
pulsechain.com there it was Richard lots
to unpack right there we're going to
cover all that fun stuff so were you
always this humble
did you always have swag were you always
confident did you always say like I'm
gonna take over the world mentality or
did they kind of have to grow into this
I always had that but really but that
don't mean you do good with girls that's
a different skill with girls yeah it's a
different explain the difference
a lot of guys they go to sales good dude
stuff good or whatever but then when it
comes to the chicks they're just then
the chicks don't like them you know what
I mean there's a different magic a
different
has has your game or uh your the way
that you you know Mack Daddy style since
you've had money I didn't used to know
nothing about fashion I used to look
stupid when I was growing up when I was
in high school I wear a Led Zeppelin
t-shirt every day that don't work bro if
you're in a Led Zeppelin t-shirt every
day you're gonna get on dates so unless
you're into the Rock stuff yeah I guess
but in my in Miami Fort Lauderdale
nobody that wasn't the vibration so so
if you like that clip click right here
to watch another or if you want to watch
the entire saucecast click right here
[Music]